hey guys it is monday the fifth of sep
tember my name is jeff and you're
watching games button use the doom ask
Shadow Warrior 2 now has a release date
and a brand-new trailer devolver digital
and flying wild hog announced that the
slash across shooter game will arrive on
pc on octobre 13 the game will run you
40 bucks while those who pre-order will
get a ten percent discount as well as
the exclusive race back chainsaw katana
owners of flying wild hogs previous
games Shadow Warrior and hard reset
redux will also be able to take
advantage of a 10-percent discount off
the pre-order price as a thank you you
can check out the full gory trailer in
our story on gamespot next up nintendo
has shut down the mario no man's sky
mashup no Mario sky the game was created
in just 72 hours as part of ludum dare
36 by a SMB games and does make use of
Nintendo IP so it's not all that
surprising that the publisher issued a
copyright claim a SMB wrote on their
website thanks everyone for playing and
enjoying our little fan game we'd love
to see an official Nintendo game in the
style a mario galaxy style game in to
date with in a procedurally generated
the universe while you can't play no
Mario sky anymore you can play their new
game dmca sky which replaces Mario with
spaceman Finn and Princess Peach with
princess mango the description reads
featuring crazy moombas an infinite
universe muscle amazing physics and a
radical spaceship dmca sky is the
hackneyed remake gone mashup evening
craving finally titanfall 2 will not be
included in EA or origin access
generally these five dollar a month
subscription services allow players to
get into EA games five days early and
save ten percent on old digital content
however in this case titanfall 2 is
excluded from the program game reactor
confirm the news which is also mentioned
on the official access faq developer
respawn indicated that titanfall 2 may
come to the service later but it won't
be there at launch although we've not
heard why the game is excluded from the
program
I yet titled two launches on october 28
for xbox one ps4 and PC let me know how
you feel about this one down in that
comment box you should head to gamespot
for stories on halo 5 and 3 for 17 and I
will see you again tomorrow